[Music]
howdy-ho reject nation I'm glad to be
here today on Tuesday to watch the third
trailer for a leta battle angel battle
ready I believe is what it's called I'm
not even gonna acknowledge the fact that
I'm doing this video alone I'm not even
gonna acknowledge the fact that John is
not here with me today he got hired by
defied media so he's off at work I know
he's taking care of them I'm excited to
check this out you know I went to go
watch Overlord the other day keep a
lookout for that review it's coming soon
when I saw this trailer IMAX you know I
know a lot of people are really looking
forward to this movie and the circles I
run in in LA a lot of people are
thinking it might not be a great film I
know it got pushed that doesn't really
bother me I'm glad I got push from
December to February because like it's
December is already so over stack when I
see this trailer knowing who's involved
I'm like I like the trailers but I bet
this movie's gonna be even better than
the trailer so I'm excited to see this
before we hop into this I gotta plug
ourselves over at our patreon we do a
lot of [ __ ] weekly Q&A is TV show
reactions for many of shows that
includes anime like attack on Titan my
hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood supernatural Gotham and
Riverdale and John does music video
coverage hello also I was thinking of
getting a Kindle because I found out
that you can read some of the comics of
battle angel Leto for free on there my
only motivation to get a Kindle so I
could feel like I know some source
material anyway let's hop into this
now Christopher wants
hello that shot
[Music]
by
you're the Assyrian person I have ever
met
you know those eyes are growing on me
[Music]
not today this girl Jennifer it is all
remember what do you mean doc found you
in scratcher so you must be from up
there and I'm just an insignificant girl
that's what the Weymouth it
I don't know what I
[Music]
that's pretty bitchin
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[ __ ] it oh yeah
[Applause]
I'm excited to watch that die really
yeah that was the best trailer out of
the mall I love the tone that this
trailer provided because you know the
other ones they tend to have like the
first half is this sense of wonder and
then it like goes dark and then a lot of
action technically this trailer seems to
follow a similar type of format however
I felt that the trailer primarily kept
it dark other than the beginning you
know like teasing at that romance
between Aleta and white boy there's
something about this trailer that seemed
like it took its time a little bit more
which allowed me to get a better sense
of its actual tone of the mystery
element to it this girls brought back to
life in some fashion and there's people
who take care of her but that she's
being hunted down they have this line in
there about like a rise of a warrior and
these action sequences everything about
it I felt more for the characters than I
have in any of the other trailers there
was something here that actually got me
very intrigued by who the characters are
and I feel like I could be really
invested in their journey where as
opposed to the other Cheddar's I was
more curious about like the world and
stuff and the visuals that all looked
really cool and appealing it was like a
fun movie this was the first time I
watched the tram like I feel a the
emotional intensity this time and the
other shows kind of had like a forced
resemblance of that and then here wow I
really feel like I could really buy into
her and also the eyes were a bother for
me in the first couple trailers but
there's something about the more I see
I've seen the same trailer in the
fever's for months now but the more I
see it the more I get used to it I feel
like once I'm past the fact that it's as
big CGI eyeballs I personally don't mind
it and also people can crap on CGI fest
films all the time but I feel like me
got that James Cameron team providing
this visual effects for this film it's
gonna be the best it's ever gonna get
and I'm excited to see this journey of a
girl go from normal girl to becoming
badass girl and it looks like all the
village he's gonna encounter are gonna
be one hell of a [ __ ] in time I'm
really looking forward to this movie it
looks like a really entertaining thrill
ride in
now I'm finally feeling that sense of
emotional intensity which I find to be
such an important factor in films that I
feel like some movies forget about and
I'm excited that it's gonna be included
here because in all honesty I really
really really want this film to do well
I mean we've gotten so many horrible
anime or manga adaptations and manga a
manga can you comment below let me know
how much of an idiot I am for not
knowing the correct pronunciation I'm
sure I'm one Google search away from
finding out but there's been so many
horrible adaptations that Americans have
tried bringing life you know there's
been ghost in the shell' there's been
Speed Racer there's been Dragonball
Evolution I didn't see Death Note but I
heard that wasn't so great I heard oh
boy I've seen both the Korean version
and the American version the American
version just is not as good as the
Korean version my one concern is that
there's a giant cast here and you know
sometimes a giant cast tends to go
wasted when you got this much caliber of
talent all in one film looking at the
IMDB you got so much more than Rosa
Salazar as Aleta and Christoph Waltz you
got Jennifer Connelly in here you got
Michelle Rodriguez you got my Hershel
ollie yeah at screen you got Jackie
Earle Haley you got Jeff Fahey yeah
Isaac and solace you have Casper Van
Dien Casper Van Dien Zinn this this
movie better do well now so yeah I
really hope this cast is not wasted
because it tends to happen with such a
big ensemble and like sometimes it's
cool to have all these names in here but
I've also seen some of these actors who
are very talented appear in films where
there are part of a larger ensemble and
they're very much ways to do you know
weirdly I'm excited for Isaac Gonzalez
because I've seen the three seasons up
from dusk till dawn and she was in that
and Robert Rodriguez brought that show
to life in terms of us needing a really
good anime adaptation I know that Warner
Brothers is working on an attack on
Titan live adaptation but like if we can
get this one right I feel like we could
have a good like if we can just nail one
that would be awesome who's gonna want
to read the mangoes because I know some
people who have read it and they said
that from looking at some of the
trailers that it does look pretty
accurate to the source material and with
that in mind I'm like okay yeah I would
love
never loved to read the source material
thing plus I know I like the music in
this trailer a lot I hope some of this
music is included in this film the whole
cast the director the production team
behind it the visual effects team behind
this film and this was the first trailer
that truly got me really invested in the
emotional journey of Aleta and the
storyline where as opposed to just
awesome visuals I feel like there's a
lack of hype a lack of buzz around this
film I don't want it to end up on
Netflix so I think we should all get
more excited for this movie anyway guys
was this your favorite trailer we look
forward to film have you read the comics
let me know listen before we wrap this
up I want to give a page from the day
shout-out to a man named Scuba Steve
Scuba Steve has an awesome Instagram
page where he does a lot of illegal
graffiti artwork you should really go
follow him and report in to the police
and make sure he still stays pledged to
our patron page but Scuba Steve I'm
constantly shouting out your Instagram
page trying to get you more followers
over there I follow him so you should
too my dad's name is Steve VIN I never
learned what the name Steve means so I
just googled it right now it says origin
of the name Steven from the Latin
Stefano's which is from the Greek
Stefano's a name derived from Stefano's
a crown a garland the name is born in
the Bible by Saint Stephen one of the
seven chosen to assist the Apostles and
the first Christian martyr
I have no jokes to go off of you are not
as important as this name leads you to
believe and nor am i vigilant and
watchful now I'm just joking to give a
skeeved you are one important guy in my
life I love you buddy and I hope you
have a happy happy Thanksgiving because
I am grateful for you well thank you for
watching you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click notification bells
and check us out on patreon we got a we
got [ __ ]